d'après
top je mesure 175 mm pour un poids de
3,5 g je suis je suis
je suis celui qui se retrouve aussi bien
par terre qu'au fond des mers je suis je
suis
je suis celui qui se reproduit à la
vitesse de trois millions d'individus
par minute je suis je suis
je suis je suis je suis celui que
verront vos arrières arrières petits
enfants je suis je suis
le masque jetable
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un best-seller
international
une pollution mondiale
durable
comment en est on arrivé là
à qui la faute
à eux
probablement
à nous
c'est possible
à moi sûrement
je m'appelle jean marc neveu ingénieur
devenu ingénieur repenti ceci est mon
histoire
revenons en arrière il ya trois ans en
tout allait bien dans le meilleur des
mondes possibles le mien
lorsque un chantier d'insertion textile
vient frapper à la porte de notre
entreprise pour nous faire part d'un
problème majeur les concernant
à chantier d'insertion textile vous
connaissez ce sont ces bornes blanches
ou colorées où vous mettez
consciencieusement vos vêtements afin
qu'ils soient collectées triées et
revendu en seconde main ce faisant vous
générer de l'activité et des revenus
pour les personnes éloignées de l'emploi
et vous fait bénéficier des vêtements à
des prix modérés
c'est parfaitement vertueux
oui mais non
il y avait 50%
oui les 50% qui ne sont pas vendables
ici que deviennent ils
eh bien ils partent à nouveau en voyage
oui parce que pour la plupart d'entre
eux ils ont fait déjà plusieurs fois le
tour de la terre avant d'atterrir sur
vos étagères donc ils partent à nouveau
en voyage d'ailleurs non loin de là où
ils ont été produits
cocasse non non parce que cette fois ci
le voyage se termine mal
quelquefois vendus ils sont pour la
plupart du temps incinérés ou enfouis ou
mis à la décharge
loin des yeux loin des caméras de
l'autre côté du monde
à l'échelle de notre chantier
d'insertion textile cela représente
quelques dizaines de tonnes à l'année
mais à l'échelle de la planète ce sont
plusieurs millions de tonnes de matières
issues
est détruite
alors que faire contre ce qu'une amie de
gâchis vestimentaire
bon en même temps moi la fast fashion
en quoi cela me concerne mais si ce
n'est moi c'est donc vous autres
et puis le problème étant posé il faut
le résoudre ingénieur un jour
ingénieurs
toujours
nous sommes mis au travail nous avons
réuni les équipes notre écosystème
et un jour l'un d'entre nous s'écria
eureka btp
eureka j'ai trouvé btp késako
broyé textile du poitou
nous avions trouvé la recette
à partir de textiles usagés
pour fabriquer une matière de bonne
qualité recyclable et industrials
power fier de cette découverte
nous allions la proposer aux grandes
enseignes de prêt-à-porter et la porte
close et oui souvenez-vous mars 2020
les magasins de vêtements avaient fermé
leurs portes
mais alors plus de vêtements plus de
pollution
problème réglé
oui mais non
de l'autre côté du monde
dans les usines qui gronde râle ivre de
coq noir trouvent ici leur déversoir
de masques jetables
nous allions assister à la plus rapide
des pollutions industrielles de
l'histoire
incorrigible humanité qui prient pour
échapper aux malheurs mais qui ne
s'opposent pas ce qui se fait pour les
attirer
comme un cri du coeur ne voulions pas
ajouter aux malheurs de la pandémie
une nouvelle pollution pour l'écologie
et si bp btp pouvez nous aider à nouveau
car à y bien regarder
le masque jeu tam est le cousin germain
du textile synthétique celui qui
composent la majorité de nos vêtements
et la magie sopera une seconde fois
en juin 2020 nous avons donc proposé
notre solution de recyclage des masques
jetables une solution circulaire
écologique et solidaire
circulaire parce que les produits que
nous allions fabriqués à partir de ces
masques serait parfaitement recyclables
une fois leur fin de vie
écologique parce que pour leur
fabrication nous n'utiliserions pas de
matière vierge
et puis solidaire parce que nous allions
créer des emplois et des formations pour
des personnes en reconversion parfait
professionnel
c'est parfaitement vertueux
et là j'ai compris quelque chose
d'important
pourquoi le mas qui pouvait apparaître
comme une solution pour la pandémie il
en était et est dans le même temps une
catastrophe pour l'écologie
et bien tout simplement
parce qu'il n'y avait pas eu en amont de
la fabrication ou la production ces
masques de réflexion sur le fan dit pas
de filière de recyclage mis en place pas
d'éco conception alors que leur
utilisation massive pouvait le laisser
supposer
mais heureusement
btp est arrivé sans se presser mais si
btp là tout va bien
et là j'ai slim et c'est une bonne y est
pourquoi n'y avons pas pensé plus tôt il
n'y avait pas pensé plus tôt
est ce que
mon point de blocage ne serait pas
connecté au coeur de ma représentation
du monde
au fondement même de ce que j'ai appris
en tant qu'ingénieur de cette vénérable
école
au principe que j'ai développé en tant
qu'industriel au modèle qu'on me demande
de suivre en tant qu'entrepreneur
les innovations technologiques
quoi qu'il en coûte
permettront de résoudre l'ensemble défi
auquel l'humanité devra faire face
l'accès à ces innovations doit mobiliser
toutes les ressources financières
cognitive matériel
ne table pas leur fin de vie d'ailleurs
de rester aurait-il encore les moyens de
le faire
pourquoi se soucier de sun fin de vie de
ces innovations
et bien tout simplement parce que au
point où nous en sommes de notre
puissance industrielle
cette représentation des choses du monde
couplé à une consommation de masse de
produits neufs impacte nos ressources
notre environnement et nos populations
de manière massive et immédiate
notre force est devenue une faiblesse
nous avons changé d'échelle accélérer le
rythme mais la terre n'est est pas
capable de suivre
une fois de plus
le poison n'est pas dans la chose mais
dans l'overdose de cette chose
prenons l'exemple de l'industrie
automobile et sa mutation du moteur
thermique au moteur électrique nous
vivons dans la même temporalité la
pénurie de ressources la pollution
associée à la fabrication de ces
batteries et la multiplication des plans
sociaux
décidément
dans un environnement contraint et
socialement responsable nous pouvons pu
concevoir nos modèles et nos produits de
la même façon
je ne veux plus être ingénieur que j'ai
été
je crois pourtant qu'il est possible de
faire muter
notre système industriel pour qu'il
puisse profiter à tous en écho quand se
vend les produits afin qu'ils soient
réellement et concrètement recyclables
en utilisant de la matière renouvelable
pour leur fabrication ou des déchets
ultimes
en incluant l'utilité sociale et
territoriale dans nos business model
je lance un appel à vous jeunes
ingénieurs vous formateurs éducateurs
designer producteurs
intégrés dans vos modèles dans vos
produits des principes d'une économie
circulaire écologique et solidaire
nous faisons déjà avec d'autres faisons
le ensemble
et pour tous les consommateurs que nous
sommes se soit réuni
je vous propose de jouer à nouveau
ce jeu s'appelle
repoussons le jour du dépassement de la
terre c'est un jeu d'équipé bien sûr
le jour du dépassement de la terre
correspond à la date du calendrier à
partir de laquelle l'humanité est
supposé avoir consommé l'ensemble des
ressources que la terre est capable de
renouveler en une année passée cette
date nous puiserons de manière
irréversible dans les ressources non
renouvelables de la planète
ce jour
cette année c'était le 29 juillet
il ya vingt ans c'était le 1er novembre
et pour la grande finale
je vous propose que au jour du
dépassement de la terre
nous n'utiliserions que les matières que
nous aurions déjà extraite
passé cette date nous ne ferions rien de
neuf
que de l'occasion ou des produits 100 %
recyclé
c'est prêt
top merci
[Applaudissements]